The thing that is the most interesting is the manipulation aspect and the interactive, individualized experience;
it’s the ability to create an intuitive sense of the underlying mathematical concept.
I work at Natixis, in investment banking, in stock derivatives.
I am in charge of the scientific calculations.
I have a team of about twenty people who work on the integration of the pricers.
One group... integrates the pricers in a way so that they go into production without difficulty.
And another group works on the calculation of sensibilities and the stress-tests.
Derivatives, those are the small variations, a small delta,
the stress-tests are large disturbances in a given market that we try to... well, that we simulate
in order to see what will happen to a stock portfolio that we’ve managed if a major problem were to arise in the market.
I used it [Mathematica] one time for an internal program called BFI Campus;
it’s a sort of internal university with a certain number of training sessions.
So, I offered to teach a session on local volatility.
It’s a concept that was “discovered,” so to speak, in the early 90s
that does not necessarily come easily to everyone.
If we approach it via pure, traditional math, in the end we have a huge obstacle to overcome before we can get a sense of what it does.
The session that I proposed is “Local volatility without math.” It’s done using the Mathematica manipulator,
the way that I demonstrate and use local volatility is via the Monte Carlo methods.
The Monte Carlo methods are extremely... calculation-heavy.
Let me say that there are plenty of advantages.
There’s the interactive graphing, the manipulators, and the controls;
the ease of development, since it’s an interpreter;
then, the speed, thanks to the compilation.
So, that’s a very valuable characteristic of Mathematica: to be able to compile like that and be able to execute the results.